hi everyone welcome to
thermo Fisher's 24 hours of stem cells
live training event so my name is Carl
targets and I'm a scientist here at
Thermo Fisher Scientific and a technique
that I want to talk to you about today
is picking pluripotent stem cell
colonies so there's a few different
reasons you might want to do this the
first and probably what most people
think of is just generally when your
cultures start differentiating you may
need to go ahead and go in and pick to
keep which means selecting pluripotent
stem cell colonies that have the correct
morphology and will be capable of
carrying on your stem cell line without
differentiation the second is in repro
reprogramming and so that's another
common technique that researchers use
and is really important as well so you
need to be able to go in and select the
colonies that are going to become your
clonal stem cell lines in that situation
and so really both of these two
situations involve the exact same
technique and so that's what I'll go
over today there is a third situation
where you might need to pick as well
however this instead of picking to keep
involves picking to remove and that's
actually physically going in and
removing differentiated cells from your
culture that may have spontaneously
differentiated and so what I'm gonna do
is go ahead and put these cells on the
microscope and we'll talk about what a
good stem cell colony looks like and why
you might want to select it when you're
picking to keep so these colonies all
look good here generally you can see
this kind of 3-dimensional structure
here is not something you'd want to pick
that's most likely differentiation and
so what I want to do is find a colony
that's the right size and has the right
morphology that we would want to go
ahead and pick
so let's find what we can hear so this
colony right here you can see that
there's some areas around it that maybe
have cells that are somewhere in between
pluripotent and differentiated and so
you want to make sure that you're only
picking the cells that are fully
pluripotent and will be able to carry on
your line without any differentiation
and so I want to show this actual
technique here if I go ahead and using a
needle that I've already prepared so
there's a lot of different tools you
could use in this situation scalpels are
fine Pasteur pipettes anything like that
in this case I have a 25 gauge needle on
a syringe here and what I'm going to do
is just go ahead and cut this colony
into a grid pattern so I'm gonna come in
and go one direction and then do the
same thing after turning the dish 90
degrees and then we'll go ahead and talk
about what we're gonna how we're gonna
remove those pieces of the colony and
add it to the next dish that we'll be
using
so as I carefully uncap my needle here
I'm gonna go in if you are using a
needle it's important to remember to
keep your bevel down
[Music]
and then you got to make sure that
keeping your colony in the center of the
plate here so you can see pardon me
let's see the tip of my needle right
there
[Applause]
so I really want to just be careful and
make nice parallel cuts I kind of by
habit I'm cutting around the edges here
and that's not so important when you're
working on a feeder free system but if
you're not working with a feeder
dependent system it's important to cut
around the edges since sometimes those
feeder cells can adhere to your colony
and if you don't cut around the edges
you might have problems getting them off
so as I mentioned I'm just gonna turn
this 90 degrees so that I can then make
perpendicular cuts to the one I have
ones I've already made
[Applause]
and again it doesn't have to be
perfectly perpendicular you can see
these are at a slight angle and that's
alright the key with choosing whatever
tool that you're using that you're not
it's not so thick that you're going to
be having problems with killing a lot of
cells where the actual needle is going
over it so what I'm going to do now is
take my p200 and again you know this is
something all these different steps I
encourage people to see what really
works for them best I prefer to use a
p200 since the size of the bore is such
that it's not so small that it's gonna
break the colony pieces into any smaller
pieces and it's not so big that I don't
have very good motor control and I'm not
able to get what I need so I'm gonna
actually go in here with my pastor pipe
or excuse me my p200 and just kind of
very gently lift those pieces off
and so need to be careful that I'm only
picking up the pieces from this colony
and then aspirating so sometimes they
might stick a little bit you need to go
in and loosen them off as you can see
for the most part I've got everything
off of the plate there and then I'm just
going to go ahead and move this to my
next plate now it's important to note
that if this were in a reprogramming
context that colony would be starting
its own clonal line so only that colony
would be going into a new well if I'm
picking to keep in a typical culture
setting then I would need to put
multiple colonies from this well into a
new well so that there's more material
to grow from so let's see if we can go
ahead and find another colony that
looked good or maybe even some
differentiation that we can remove so I
can show you that technique as well
[Applause]
here's another good-looking colony so
I'm gonna go ahead and do the same
technique so as you remember I'm going
in here with my needle and just making
one set of cross-hatched lines so that
was not as straight on that one that'll
happen sometimes and that's totally okay
and just need to keep making your cuts
and not worry about it
give me up sorry hit the edge there
and sometimes on these it can be tough
you can lose where your actual tip of
your needle is
sorry
[Applause]
yes I'm having some trouble here I think
I'm gonna actually switch the tip of the
needle sometimes those can get dulled a
little bit so I'm gonna put that in the
sharps there and grab a new one and so
as I mentioned picking to remove is
important too so after we some
differentiation and then we can go ahead
and scrape that off and typically what I
use for that is the P 200 so again
lines don't look quite as straight as
they did on the last one but that's okay
we're still making this into a smaller
pieces that we're going to be able to
effectively pick up so again I'm kind of
cutting over the edge here
there we go so not my best work but you
can see there's still pieces here that
we're able to pick up and actually then
we're going to just go ahead and turn
that 90 degrees and do the same thing
again
so that looks a little better you know
sometimes they do get bunched up a
little bit and that's definitely
possible that that may cause a little
differentiation with it when it sits
down but again that's why you want to
make sure whether you're doing
reprogramming or just picking a keep
normally you're doing this several
different times and picking lots of
colonies because if one doesn't work out
the way you want it to or it doesn't sit
down for any reason you you should be
able to do multiples so that you're
successful
[Applause]
so now I'm just gonna go in again with
my p200 and kind of gently ease those
pieces of the colony off the plate and
aspirate those up as I do it there may
be some little pieces here stuck and
that's okay those are most likely too
small to sit down and form a colony
anyway so now I'm just gonna add that to
my plate here so I mentioned picking to
remove and again I think that generally
picking to keep or picking to your
pluripotent colonies is a much more
common technique but it's important to
note both and I would say even picking
to remove is a little bit easier since
really all you're doing is just scraping
those cells off the plate and then
you'll end up rinsing and removing them
so let's see if we can find a little
differentiation here real quick so again
I mentioned some of these other areas
that are somewhere in between fully
differentiated and pluripotent something
like this where you can see the
difference between cells you can
actually see space between the cells
whereas the normal pluripotent colony
colony has that really tight morphology
that refractive edge and behind nucleus
to cytoplasm ratio
so something like these again a little
more what we're looking at removing
sometimes it'll be look just like a
fully differentiated somatic cell and
sometimes it'll just be like a colony
that started to look a little different
so we can go in here and just remove and
then as you know so now these cells are
floating in the media itself so you need
to make sure that you go in and rinse
the media several times before you're
done with it because if you leave those
differentiated cells or if you passage
them they'll just going to end up in
your cultures going forward great so
with that I just want to summarize
things I talked about so when you're
picking a keep there's basically two
major reasons you'd want to do that one
is reprogramming so you're selecting a
pluripotent stem cell colony that's
gonna become your clonal cell line the
second is when you have a fairly
differentiated dish and you want to
select from it the pluripotent cells and
pluripotent colonies that you want to go
on and continue that cell line and then
lastly if you have a fair amount of
differentiation as well you may want to
go in there and actually physically
remove the differentiation instead of
selecting the pluripotent cells that you
have and so those are the three main
areas and again that criteria that we
look at for selecting the pluripotent
stem cells when we do is that refractive
edge of those colonies the high nucleus
cytoplasm ratio and those really tight
those colonies should be really tight
with cells that are difficult to
distinguish from one another
so with that I'm just gonna take any
questions that there might be and we'll
move from there
thank you very much for that
demonstration Karl I'm sure our viewers
are a lot more confident about picking
colonies after watching that of course
there are things that participants may
want to dig into or clarify and so my
name is John everyone and like Karl I'll
work on the thermal Fisher's stem-cell
products I will be moderating today's
Q&A session so please if you haven't yet
please type in your questions into the
chat and I will read them for you Karl
the first question which was sent in
earlier is this what magnification are
you using on your microscope that's a
good question Joanna so this is actually
a 5x I've seen people use 10 but in
general for something that involves such
fine motor skills I find that a higher
magnification makes it easier again now
I mentioned this with several things
including the the different tools you're
using to do the actual picking and
things like that but you know people
should really try whatever they can and
see what works best for them if you know
you like doing it at 20x which is
something I'm not comfortable with then
and that works for you then by all means
you should do it so I really encourage
people to try a lot of different things
and see what works because this is as I
mentioned a really important technique
that you're gonna be utilizing a lot
right and here's another question from
the same participant why can't you just
aspirate the entire colony using a p200
tip is the segmentation necessary sure
so if you were to go in and remove an
entire colony with a P 200 or aspirate
it with a P 200 you're gonna get very
heterogeneous sizes of the chunks from
that colony which can be a lot more
problematic generally as long as you're
comfortable with the technique you
should be able to get similarly sized
colony pieces and that will make for a
more
culture going forward so you you could
do that but I think in general you're
gonna wind up with a much more
heterogeneous population and more likely
to differentiate and less likely to have
your colony pieces sit down right and
this is going back a little bit you show
it obviously how to pick the colonies
but how would a colony be identified by
a novice an appropriate one for picking
right so as I mentioned there's kind of
like three main things you want to look
at with pluripotent stem cell morphology
in general the first is how those cells
are really tightly packed together you
can't really distinguish one from
another when they start to separate from
each other that's usually a sign that
they're on their way towards
differentiation the second thing is that
they have a tight refractive edge and so
that's something you can identify on the
microscope itself and if you want we can
go back to the screen at any time but
you can see colonies like this one here
in the center of the microscope screen
really have that distinct edge that's
completely separate from the substrate
itself and you can I easily identify
where the colony starts and begins this
can be a little more difficult if you're
using feeder cells but that Tiger
effective edge should still be there the
last thing is high nucleus to cytoplasm
ratio which often times you may have to
zoom in on the colonies to really see
but that's something to keep in mind
still but I'd really focus on those
first two things the tight refractive
edge and the tight colony where the
cells are very close together
and do you have any advice for reducing
the spontaneous differentiation in the
first place absolutely so that's
something that's really important to do
because you know you don't have
differentiation then obviously you don't
have to remove it which is great the
main thing that I would do in that case
would be very consistent with your
feeding depending on the media you're
using but you know most people are
feeding every day
at the same time you never want your
cells to get the media to get acidified
that's a common cause of differentiation
you want to also be consistent about
removing any small amounts of
spontaneous differentiation that are
occurring in your culture each passage
if you skip a passage then it's more
likely for that to build up over time
and eventually take over your culture so
that's another big thing the time out of
the incubator is also very important if
you're leaving your cells on a
microscope for a long time the
temperature might be dropping and that
is a common cause of differentiation all
these things really come into play but
in general you just want to be very
careful and take really good care of
your stem cells much more so than you
would with any other type of cell
because they're very finicky all right
here's another question do you ever use
the aspirator to clean the plate that is
something I have done in the past if
some I know some microscopes may have
like a marker on the bottom or something
like that where you can actually
physically mark places of
differentiation that's a great technique
if you have access to a marker like that
or something usually there's a circle or
something of that nature and so you
would have to go and physically mark all
over the plate if you are doing that
with a plate that's very very
differentiated it's really going to take
a long time and so you might be better
off picking to keep but if there's a
reasonable amount of differentiation
that you can mark and then go in and
actually a spray that that's a great
technique as well we don't have that on
this
instrument but that's another option
that people can use and how do you
remove differentiate that sells just
around the edge of a colony if there's
I'm sorry if there's sells just outside
the edge of the colony happy yeah so
typically what I would do is then go
into the center of the colony and only
cut the middle out if I'm worried about
accidentally grabbing some cells from
the outside I would take just the very
inside of it because as you can see you
know sometimes it's a little difficult
to get you know the whole colony the way
you want it and not get anything from
the outside and say you did accidentally
include some parts of the differentiated
sections how do you fix that mistake
sure again that depends on whether or
not you're doing a reprogramming picking
or picking to keep in terms of just a
normal cell line so if you're keeping it
for a normal cell line you're picking
say five or ten colonies that are all
going into the same plate you get a
little bit of differentiation that
should be fine in a reprogramming
setting that's going to have a larger
effect so as long as you have plenty of
colonies to choose from I would go ahead
and then remove aspirate that well and
not use that colony if you picked up
differentiation
this one is changing the angle a little
bit what are the benefits of hand
picking over a bulk passage in your
agent that may distinguish between
different kinds of cells that's a good
question so typically as long as your
differentiation levels are relatively
low you really want to make sure you're
doing both casting because again that's
gonna be overall more consistent and
allow you to do things much quicker so
your workflow will be a lot too sped up
quite a bit the the problem occurs when
you have a lot of differentiation and
you're not able to pick to remove all of
the differentiation in the plate as long
as you're able to remove everything in
the plate in a relatively short amount
of time you're fine to do both passages
however if there's so much that you feel
like the differentiation has sort of
taken over then that's when you go in
and actually take the pluripotent stem
cell colonies out and pick to eat right
and that's just thinking about the
maintenance of the pluripotent stem
cells right there are specific
applications where you need to pick
specific colonies as I mentioned in
reprogramming you don't have that luxury
unless you don't care about clonal cell
lines at all but most people when
they're doing a reprogramming want to
isolate individual clones that form
those colonies and so that's when you
have to be very careful about only
selecting one colony at a time that goes
into one well at a time to form those
funnel cell lines
and so in the case where someone is
required to pick their colonies is it
possible to pick colonies without the
use of a cabinet screen microscope is
there I have seen setups where you're in
more of a dissection scope however more
mostly you want to stay within a laminar
flow hood because the chance of
exceeding of contamination becomes very
high if you take it outside of it in
general even within a laminar flow hood
this is your most likely time the
differentiated contamination will occur
and so it's a really time you need to be
really careful and make sure and that's
something actually I didn't mention
during the demonstration that I probably
should have so I want to you know hit on
that point a little more this is the
most likely time that contamination will
occur you have your plate open and so
you need to be careful about passing
your hand over the edge of the plate and
because typically stem cells are
cultured without antibiotics it's even
more likely that'll occur so you have to
be very very careful throughout this
entire process this is sort of related
just a little bit what is the maximum
time that you'd be comfortable leaving
cells outside the incubator that's a
great question and I as with all these
it does depend on the specific cell line
you're working with but I wouldn't want
to have them out for more than twenty or
thirty minutes at a time so I would say
you know you get them out look at them
and then just kind of start a time or
something like that and be aware of how
long it's taking if you know it ends up
being that you need more time than that
I would recommend you know going through
if you have other plates and doing that
first or bringing those back out again
you don't want your temperature to be
consistently lower than 37 degrees
centigrade for too long
excellent we are seeing a number of
thank-you messages here too just so you
know Carl they're finding this very
helpful here's one question when picking
colonies how many pieces should each
colony be separated into and how large
should each piece be sure also very good
question so how many pieces they
separate into really depends on the size
of the colony so if you have a smaller
colony that'll be fewer pieces and if
you have a very large colony that would
be many more in general if the colony is
so small that you can't make more than
it into more than four pieces I
generally would say you shouldn't be
picking it but most likely that colonies
not ready to be picked as far as the
size of the chunks themselves I think
that it's important to try to be as
consistent as possible calling it a
colony and really it's more of a law of
averages so you need to find the kind of
middle ground between so large that it's
gonna sit down and fold over on itself
and cause differentiation and so small
that it actually won't be able to sit
down and adhere to the plate so
something in the middle generally is
what you're looking for and so basically
if you saw what I was cutting that's
about the right size but again I think
this is something that it will just take
practice and depends on what you're
doing and what works for you
and you showed not just picking of
colonies but the removal of you know
differentiation how much differentiation
necessitates either removal of those
differentiated areas or picking a colony
in order to keep it sure as long as it's
noticeable differentiation
I recommend removing it as far as how
much actually necessitates picking to
keep I'd say if you have more than 20 to
30% of your plate that's fully
differentiated on a feeder free system
that numbers a little higher on the
feeder dependent system and if you have
more than you know say 40 percent on
feeder dependent that's when you
probably need to go in and actually
select your play button cells to
continue the line that means the
differentiation is starting to take over
great and this is a question that goes
into kind of reagents I'm not sure if
I'm understanding it correctly so if not
these send in a clarification but do you
ever have to add inhibitors as you pick
colonies I imagine something may be like
a rock inhibitor sure that's something
you can do it's necessary we typically
don't do that just to kind of keep the
cells in there you know normal state
where they're not being perturbed at all
but that's something that if you're
having trouble with
viability after picking colonies that
you can get a shot itself and more
generally a question on how many
colonies typically grow per per dish I
don't know an exact number but hundreds
of colonies depending on the size of the
dish of course we typically culture ours
in either six well plates or sixty
millimeter dishes in both of those there
would be hundreds of colonies and also
it's worth keeping in mind that the
colonies will start to grow together
especially in a feeder free system by
the time they're about 70 percent
confluent which is when you want a
passage and that's something that later
today and another one of the live
trainings that Chad will be talking
about in general with both passages is
the confluence II and wind the passage
but yeah many hundreds of colonies will
be growing in one plate at a time
and they'll start to grow together in a
feeder Polly system by the time they
reach 70 percent frequency which
another question just came in what do
you do if you accidentally cut a colony
into uneven or very small pieces sure
that's a great question generally
speaking I would say you want to just go
ahead and press forward and use the
material you have so long as you didn't
pick up any differentiation in it that
said if it's the cell colonies have been
completely broken into very very small
pieces they may not sit down but unless
that's the case I would say you want to
just go ahead and move forward and take
the colonies anyway and see what happens
and that'll also inform your picking
later to see what actually is capable of
sitting down and forming you know
pluripotent lines and what is it
and one final question which I found
very interesting they're apologizing
because this might be too far-fetched
but could we engineer new plates so as
to reduce the technique error maybe pre
divided quadrant plates or which which
could be picked with colony I could to
help us pick the colonies sure I
definitely heard of micro machine plates
for different applications usually in
differentiation contexts where one
colony will grow and then they'll
differentiate that into a specific cell
type but something like that could
certainly work I do think that it's
important to make sure that the media is
probably shared between them as there's
a lot of growth factors and other things
that cells are spitting out especially
if you're working with feeders on feet
or free that may not be the case but
something like that could potentially
work for sure for sure
all right I think that's a wrap for
today's live training event on picking
colonies thank you again Carl for
demonstrating and thank you everyone for
joining us here 24 hours of stem cells
does run for many more hours today with
scientific talks and many thermo Fisher
resources at your disposal if we didn't
get to your question there are other
opportunities to ask those in our booth
and perhaps those questions could be
answered through our other training
sessions as well thank you again
you